[Musique]
c'est l'avenir était
mettons comment il peut vous l'imaginez
liés ou encore qui va venir effet votre
raisonnement est que vous là pour crier
mon métier consiste à participer à des
animations des faces a fait éclore
d'élèves de personnes sont passées
d'aborder ensuite à suivre
quels sont tes projets la lauréate de
l'organisation sur le terrain
je vais donc vous faire une analogie
entre la construction d'une maison et la
composition des lanes la première étape
lanceront commencent à porter son projet
de maison des d'identifier le dr un peu
d'identifier imaginez donc découvert ou
de la fin la maison de bourg est un pur
on l'imaginé immeubles maisons
écologiques en harmonie avec la nature
d'autres encore vous l'imaginez en
périphérie de la ville
un cousin approche va profiter des
espaces environnants et donc encore pour
en imaginer en bordure de mer ne pouvant
profiter du bruit de l'océan à toute
heure du jour ou de la nuit
à chaque plein tarif et tout fait maison
tous furent elles ont en commun le fait
qu'il y avait derrière une vidéo qu'il
ya eu derrière un processus et des états
qui ont donc permis à le faire après les
clubs et avant-hier
bon de se réaliser la première et passe
donc quand nous parlons des 11 et à leur
aile à l'identification du terrain le
choix du type ce soit du fils
on peut le comparer dans notre vie
personnelle à la défense une fois que le
site est choisi
on va repartir à la recherche du
financement on va partir à la recherche
des vestaires des professionnels et nous
nous permet de donner vie à notre projet
ou mieux encore niveau nous permet de
consolider et de rendre le projet en lui
donnant demain cet état quand on l'a
longtemps fait le parallèle avec la
vicomté bla bla du personnel fait d'être
présent cl oui nous venons la
préparation de notre enfance et nous
mettons en contact avec notre premier
environnement
ça va être les premiers à vis de la
famille une trentenaire ou encore
pharrell les premiers moments on peut
fêter en communauté ces premiers moments
où il faut apprendre à lire il faut
apprendre à lire et donc c'est les
premiers
les premières difficultés également que
le roi une fois que les professionnels
du métier ont donné leur avis sur le
projet il s'agira donc d'établir les
fondations de ce projet sans fondations
le projet n'est pas évident donc pour le
prêt de personnel qui identifie des
étapes appel de la formation
tout effort a fait de l'éducation du
tout fort elle pourra être sous forme
intellectuelle
ce trajet de l'éducation spirituelle
gestation aurel et donc c'est une barque
antibuée affaires de l'homme la personne
qui m'a dit si tu va le former et de
construire une fois cette étape pour
effectuer nous aurons celle de la
charpente et de la couverture
cette étape je lis lundi puis à celle de
la profession est également à celle de
la sécurité des centrales
un emploi ou à la sécurité comme la
famille dit il hier peu importe les
difficultés que nous avons fait que
cette ouverture fait sécurité donc nous
prouvant montfort vous professez taxe
effectivement nous aurons les soins
définition il s'agira de choisir le
carrelage qui vous en doutez pas de
choisir les sanitaires la peinture est
ainsi de tous les états ne les identifie
à celle du soir du mode de vie ou à 16
soit des amis ou des premières relations
c'est les papous léger messieurs vont
chercher à se poser avec une demoiselle
par exemple et ou mesdames vous c'est
vrai peut-être vous sentation de ces
messieurs après l'étape définition nous
avons fait de l'aménagement intérieur et
de l'année
en extérieur il s'agira de déterminer au
niveau de notre intérieur
quels sont les choix de mi saison il se
passera du terme de déterminer au niveau
de notre état extérieur si nous
souhaitons adopter pour installer ici
par exemple pour installer un espace de
loisirs est ainsi depuis les étapes que
les identifie à celle des patients et
désagréments qui vont permettre de nous
épanouir qui vont contribuer à notre
équilibre personnel
une fois que ces étapes sont franchies
nous avons notre maison vous avez
emprunté un plaisir nous avons notre
seigneur nous allons penser nous allons
ajouter votre maison pendant un an
pendant deux ans notre vision et voudra
montréal a rappelé heures de temps en
temps à l'entretenir de combattants
s'étaient pas vus identifie appel de
l'autoformation pour pérenniser les
différentes choses que nous avons acquis
durant le temps c'est l'époque où il
faut pérenniser notre intégrité notre
dignité également tout en transmettant
des savoir faire à notre environnement
la maison et conclut au fil du temps
qu'elle est une empreinte écologique est
ce que il s'agit de aujourd'hui nous
parlons beaucoup de développement
durable nous parlons d'économie
d'énergie et faire notre pays et qu'on
m'a pris et finalement d'hommes peu à
l'environnement mais en beaucoup
est-ce que sur le plan personnel ce que
nous avons indiqué que nous en faisons
et ce que nous le mettons en pratique l
autre
non est ce que nous nous formons
d'autres personnes également à fatick
bénéficier de nos compétences
vous avez sûrement entendu parler de ces
maisons sans fondations solides ghz pour
un jour écoulé parce qu'il ya un aspect
de la maison qui n'était pas il n'a pas
imaginable de du monde des normes qu'il
fallait vous me direz comment construire
une maison de manière mesurable et de
manière intéressante de manière pérenne
je dirais qu'il faut construire sa
maison en impactant l'environnement de
manière le plus positif aux petits
picots construit sa maison en entonnant
le positif je sue le positif que nous
avons à l'intérieur du bus durant du
parcours il est important avant les
vivres il est navrant d'avoir des
modèles de réussite lointaine sur
laquelle nous pouvons nous appuyer ces
modems réussite vont nous permettre de
nous élever vous nous inspirer et nous
permet d'atteindre nos objectifs de la
chance d'avoir plusieurs modèles pour
mémoire des martyrs qui me donne de
l'énergie qui me donne la persévérante
qui me permet d'être persévérant et qui
m'étonne de la détermination afin
d'atteindre mes objectifs est l'une des
têtes un fait mais tout simplement ma
mère qui m'a qui a su me donner l'amour
du travail qui a su me donner de la
vigueur dans tout je faisais et qui a dû
me donner légalement de l'excellente
qu'il faut appliquer dans chaque étape
de sa vie et elle a su à mons ont
participé de manière notable à la vente
et elle a notamment construit une école
primaire donc qui à mon sens est le
meilleur endroit pour inculquer les
valeurs vous transmet des valeurs mais
elle a su également contribué en donnant
d'elle même et en contribuant à
l'éducation
de nombreux jeunes citoyens de ce pays
[Musique]
jeune offre trois valeurs dont
l'importance pour la construction de
l'avenir
il s'agit au delà de l'éducation de soi
et de méditation peut transmettre et ça
lui va voir la fois il s'agit de pouvoir
revoir son projet
quoi qu'il arrive il s'agit aussi
d'établir un plan d'action
ce plan d'action va nous permet
d'établir un procès va nous permettre
d'établir une feuille de route que nous
allons suivre tout à petit et enfin
l'excellent fois à sion excellente 3000
films sans importance d'utiliser au
quotidien pour la notion de la cuillère
ses thèmes favoris sont chaque jour peut
paraître une petite goutte dans l'océan
mais elle manquerait aussi ancien
existait pas et dont il me semble
important de sang fait poser un acte de
bacs de pâtir de notre quotidien ce
châtiment
nous sommes là seulement que femme la
somme d'expériences que d'autres ont
fait de me prendre les clés de ma propre
expérience mais rien d'important parce
que l'avenir nous n'y pouvons pas celle
où nous entend ils forment la porte en
droit de pouvoir constituer une synergie
des actions atteindre afin de construire
un meilleur avenir possible
j'avais l'image donc d'intérieur ou de
maison qui traduisent la glace de la
meilleure idéal
maison donc les effectivement nommés- os
que nous la construisons pour appuyer du
monde étaient ou sont souvent justes
pour détacher
la problématique est est elle a annoncé
et je vous invite tous à identifier en
tout cas il n'est jamais trop tard
proposer une action
il n'est jamais trop tard pour
contribuer à construire l'avenir est le
meilleur moment augmenter bien tout
simplement
c'est maintenant
[Musique]